knowing welcome to this Rapids game on a
chess-playing Merrick mister become
probably and yeah it's glossy form Marek
em all become so um c-46 now there are a
couple of things now g3 is my main move
but I also play Knight c3 and d3
sometimes let's do this it's an
interesting line times the Slav yeah a
six year I had the same thing with black
ones in a game but I fail to remember
how that continued I remember there was
cream be three at some point but I
wonder how I get down
it will be three here doesn't make any
sense
I could see - maybe or something let's
play Quincy - I don't quite remember
what happens after a six
okay so probably be three now default
would transpose to a semi sloth which is
okay of course but not the point of
delaying the multiform
so he played a six but did not really
yeah follow up on that all that much
would be six interesting okay let's
develop yeah the interesting thing is
that his d'Alene his son Bishop on f8
one idea for white is to play an early
g4 and this makes no sense probably no
sense now as after capturing rook g1 he
can just go back there's not a g7 pawn
hanging what I can do is I can play d4
because what he did is a little bit
weird with this a six a six is a mostly
useless move okay I can also cast off
first
let's careful first
we should be sixes very likely to happen
okay that's not bad either so there
probably have to do it
the White has two plans and disposition
moles claim one is okay now we get
something entirely different what's to
play a form or play something to 95 when
he took them so the alkane politics it's
not not a huge decision
okay so here I would like to play d5
under favorable circumstances I can
actually play it now because he cannot
take twice as g7 is hanging d5 he takes
pawn takes maybe is got b5 but then I
have before and what is doing is quite
slow oh yeah so good that looks like the
most aggressive tribe I could have just
played a route to the one I grew
ft-1 on also a four a five came into
consideration but this looks like the
most straightforward thing you know so
b5 now or castles if he cancels he has
to when it can cancel maybe as d5 might
be hanging for real now when I had would
be one if you cancels I can go look d1
threatened d6 and then ask then I have
time to play a form I would like to get
a foreign okay question is which route f
d1 or a d1
afterward ad one yeah I think this is
right he will play Bishop d6 here most
likely and down in this scenario a later
92 and then f-4e form of the central
pour NOLA it's probably um probably on
the cards okay that's interesting
because it uses the six tactic open in
some cases four four four
okay anyway I think I have to do this
maybe not strictly have to do it but it
makes perfect sense so to get rid of B 5
B five he gets us in the oil says this
before I D and trying to dislodge my c3
Knight register the backbone here of the
Sun central structure Knight d2 to see
form of course that would be really nice
not possible now at least that is a
pretty tough decision to just give up
the h-bomb okay so what am I going to do
there are some possible ideas I can try
to play strictly for the poem roller
like g3 move the knight like even to h4
and then e 4f for that that it is very
straightforward and probably dangerous
the other thing that came to my
attention is Queen to f5 try to bring
yeah trying to use the Queen not sure
about this
yes I think I'm going for the corn
roller not not so easy though I mean the
Queen move was interesting
if he goes 95 now I think I'll probably
go to h4 intending night at 5 or playing
f1
no that makes sense so that was the idea
it's not easy to allow an idea 5 in this
pollution g6 is also
energy six is not a movie I'd like to
play if he plays g6 I probably go eform
eform we're cool and then a gay is f45
just go for the steamroller one scenario
that can easily happen here is that I'm
pushing this and then you will sacrifice
for the center it's probably good for
white but not easy to claim please not
this is not really simple to claim
I wonder if phone no you're thinking a
bishop [ __ ] form and supporting
everything but then 95 is always coming
so that doesn't do anything
yeah maybe black-owned and this is this
is of course an idea to get the c5
square for the bishop all right okay
or Bishop before us also interesting
trying to maybe take this and lessen my
control over you for giving up the dark
squared bishop though is not not an easy
thing to do
okay I think f4 is that's probably
premature premature I don't know it
looks very very loose for me
yeah it's night I would like to get this
night back into the game
90 just 9 f3 for 94 or 92 that's not a
clear situation really
I mean f4 is by far by far the most
principled move and to maybe Bishop f3
and 92 back okay if I go F form and put
the bishop on f3 my king should be in
quite save on h1
like that the only move that they make
some sense the other player may have
left the game
why because I used the time maybe he
didn't think I was disconnected or
something this is a record game I hope
he didn't left he didn't leave
I take a moment down
now that does look good yeah ice back
that's good
wouldn't have liked to win this game by
where this thing that it's an
interesting position really so what is
he going to do
I was thinking Bishop c5 it's still
tricky for him I mean the night here has
no squares here to go to him so checking
h1 and then what don't see any piece
sacrifice working on you for so and they
have Bishop f3 that's something that I
only saw a little bit late that helps a
lot yeah plugging the day diagonal and
making me fire a realistic option again
oh that's not something ahead on the
radar very interesting so I cannot take
it due to you for hanging okay wait wait
wait I can't take it I can't take it but
he will check me and then if I go back
then you for saying okay oh oh I should
have seen
oh it is not good not good at all
ah cool that's a big issue oh my god
for felts felt wrong somehow sometimes
you should trust your intuition I kind
of talked myself into this and my
initial feeling was that this is not a
good move and then I had further carrots
the only move that really yeah that has
a logical flow to it somehow but um it's
awful that's really awful him Nate's got
before and then c3 and my position
completely sucks
[Music]
yeah deform I don't know something
better even before 92 c3 that looks
terrible for me this one okay
don't expect us okay
not saying is bad because I did not have
it on the radar at all what a bad
position here okay yeah c3 c3 bishop c1
and everything looks bad can you
[Music]
remarkable the only thing if I can
somehow get 90 for b3 and then things
would be a little bit less terrible but
I have to check for all kinds of tactics
on the long diagonal like 90 form we can
pluck off the take on a form this should
take rook takes Queen takes bishop takes
d5 you know maybe 94 94 93 this work I
know it's got Queen Queen C form yeah
and first of all it's black smooth
so I'm just checking if I have this
option 94 at all
and okay am i threatening e5 in this
particular moment I think I maybe do
well d5 95 I can take the six that
should work
I'm really not certain if it helped him
to play this Quincy five check I mean he
could have had a very similar position
with the Queen being flexible okay so he
went back with the scanning out of them
immediate immediate for EM you know what
to do
94b three would be really helpful okay
is he threatening something no not not
yet yeah okay maybe this for Bishop III
who should be three and potentially
getting no I don't know it looks very
looks like a lame move okay we have to
speed up a little bit
maybe 93 and d5 is also an option
it looks very weird now I'm not sure God
a lot orders 85 Bishop a6 is something
that you can try or just play b3 and
trying to play b3 with some move
[Music]
I think I'm threatening we should be 394
years that I don't know what it plays
here and then I play let's say place a 5
or 7 Bishop III and 94 it's not bad I
feel my position is not good but I don't
quite see how he's going to do it
you
then let you to us may be a sensible
move we have the night on edge for the
only purpose there were would would have
been some piece a crow physis and the
balsa didn't look very realistic here at
least it supports you should be three
and turn the other like it helps to
coordinate pieces I so not it seems he
does not find anything good running and
this I have thought about but I thought
Bishop III is good Queen eight five and
then ninety form maybe I'm wrong I can
also go ninety-four immediately
Queen to a5 maybe coming night the night
b3 probably it does not look that
convincing he also has night c4 in some
cases okay let's do this
and Cooney's five
okay Knight b3 queen takes and then
maybe d6 or something like that
now we for is hanging that doesn't work
the knight c6 also comes into
consideration to have a five later
all night III trying to support e5 but
he's so often on d5 this is probably
almost never working 93 create for this
should be three night c4 is
unfortunately pretty good for him
maybe fall to the snow I still want to
blunder this pawn to d6 so I'm giving up
this pawn for the sake of pushing maybe
has some tactic like 94 so no probably
not
[Music]
doesn't quite add up the whole thing
still not threatening v6 because because
of the week off for corn I don't know I
just don't know what to do if I push
this back at least the pressure is a bit
weed used
now not too bright 97 probably on I
don't know maybe a syntactic any place
for tactics cannot cover it really I
just does not need to be all that bad
that that is a pretty annoying porn so
whatever he does I probably go queen F
to try to play for an attack nineteen so
ever is some sort of self pin so I don't
need to move the Queen necessarily
and my position is still a bit strange
them okay so I'm queen f2 white looks
correct we wants to move those 93
let's go then and now I've pinned I've
pinned myself ok Knight to f5 I need to
go to f5 and have Bishop e3 so probably
here
oh that's a good move unfortunately
really good move getting this is very
very bad
that he gets this bishop it was very
important hope at least for some plane
[Music]
man g-49 h6 dozen to work you have to do
something
d5 is almost hanging empty - look see -
yeah not a move I like to play it you
can take the five now or this one still
not threatening Knight h6 sf6 sir she's
got this under control
Jesus check
all right he threatens this one I'm
going to get a kanji fire now we just
played nicely cannot cannot do much
about it
okay I don't know Jim ff1 I mean I
really had this how much that I
shouldn't play it and then I still
played it I'm not sure maybe I actually
had some chances later still it's really
tough the same and yeah and the thing is
I don't think that like here this must
be good for Y down to a fairly certain
giving me the central dominance cannot
be the right choice so um yeah you can't
really argue about all this if I should
do this I can play on in a more
centralized way like here with fos the
engine suggests night to d2 but I mean I
don't think this can be that bad
actually
so g6 and yeah then equal f4 yeah
yeah I should bring it back to f3 as
well at what I've said during the game
but then I did not have to say I just
did not see b5 which is a bit
embarrassing other than that other
without b5 I'm really okay with a
terrible game usually I manage with this
without a blunder and F matrix three
year
anyway that is prolly not sure I mean
around here and it's very fishy anyway
yeah he's five given by the engine but
the head that didn't really consider
this because I thought he d5 is just
hanging but this is not the KS iam no it
is the case 94
yeah so this isn't this isn't that great
and then maybe they need to maybe be
five in Antakya
but what does it what does the end don't
give Queen b6 actually and then just be
formed now that it is just now like oh I
should have trusted my instinct there
really that this is crap and now this
was really really awful I was thinking
like that after this stuff here at night
to b6 that I am somehow getting back
into it but 94 was bad young B should be
three was better and then taking b6 oh
my god I let that's ugly
yeah but maybe I have to do it at least
I get e fivin man that's true I was
thinking I might have enough here but it
all didn't work him Knight b3 Bishop III
doesn't work at the end of plague dozen
which I'm just collapsing them
you
now I'm just fishing yeah but there's
nothing I was thinking during the game
maybe that was New York to North
opportunity with Gavin he okay
FTX g6 and Bishop a tribe Wow
I can't didn't have all that much time
now it's heading straight forward saying
what does that I still take of course
how interesting so there was a challenge
but double at that time we had we didn't
have much time left and some ship h5
okay that's not really a blunder they
both lose so what's the point yeah
nicely done by my opponent I mean I
really I really should have trusted my
mistake there that f4 is a bad move it
was a bang I did not see why yeah you
know I didn't see b5 concretely return